just hold it yes this whole day all
right okay all right
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Gustav and here's my baby if
I see a baby at the grocery store my
goal is to make it smile I'm seeing it
through my wife's eyes we are thinking
about having a baby pretty soon not like
a big kid some kids like me I think they
sense that energy we got a thing going
on all the try guys will agree that I
have the least paternal instinct but I
have the most dogs today we're gonna
change Khan's diaper that's not
something we've ever done before
be quick you hold them up like a oh my
like a that's chicken I've changed every
oh okay keep it on it the rest of us
have zero experience alright I got this
make your wife proud grab the legs which
one to the front I don't know I know I'm
sorry this is this is terrifying
Oh we'll wipe wipe wipe wipe wipe wipe
clean and off your penis you're missing
the winner you know sometimes I just
don't you wipe the winners right you
gotta wipe the winner I got it right
this is all that goes into taking care
of a baby it's just jumping so nailed it
hey now I am confused
cold air sometimes them you know look at
this guy you want to take into the
dancing classes
okay but he's so delegated do it we go
and down we go manhandle be a like move
food what happened oh I broke something
No
oh is it yeah what did you make sure his
penis was born in what direction there's
baby I'm just scared I don't want to
hurt him well dogs are easier because I
can accidentally drop my dogs
you just complements to make them quit
you good cats buddy you work out you
have a really electric personality that
is a sloppy diaper son it's on oh he
doesn't want me to touch you finally
found one thing Eugene isn't good at
what song you know really sing took on
like Turkish baby songs I know all I
know neither of us want to be in this
position we're here so when you make the
best of it it was really fun but how I'm
exhausted I'm starting to sweat it's a
lot of hard work but the reward is worth
it I feel like I'm holding the priceless
rule I can't wait
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'll just give him back the frame you
want okay thank you you're drinking